purely effective extremely agile very
quickly therefore also had
to high-risk interventions and therefore their
complete mobilization on this operation shows
all the importance in fact of people
who are not arrested
all the difficulty when several
police forces like that is the army
intervene  it is the coordination between
all the forces that have discussed it is
to have a very great cohesion in fact
at the level of the fantasy of
intervention all of its military and
other units which will for some make the
closure for d  other intervention
are not accustomed to working together
and therefore there may be and many
studies there may also be
blunders are made in the
transmission of orders or in the
performance of certain missions and
therefore it takes coordinators of  very
high level
thank you very much to christophe coppin we
learn that there is therefore a school which is
right next door
the children are put in protection  ion of course
on this security perimeter we are
not currently broadcasting an image will say
because all the media have been
kept away from this rue des quatre-vents